hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video I'm
going to show you six different ways on
how to check a temperature first let's
talk about what is a normal body
temperature in the adult it can vary
anywhere between 97 degrees to 99
degrees Fahrenheit with the average
about ninety eight point six and a child
it can also vary anywhere between ninety
seven point four to around a hundred
degrees Fahrenheit and anything greater
than a hundred point four is considered
a fever in both adult and child the
first way we're going to check a
temperature is through the mouth
so orally and you can do this one of two
ways you can use a digital thermometer
which is most commonly used or you can
use a glass thermometer which really
isn't used as much because they can
break so let me show you first how to
use this glass thermometer before taking
an oral temperature you want to make
sure that the person hasn't consumed
anything and if they have wait about
fifteen minutes before taking the
temperature so what you want to do is
you want to perform hand hygiene and
dawn gloves
anytime you're taking an oral
temperature you may be encountering oral
secretions say you want to prevent
yourself from getting contaminated then
you want to make sure your thermometer
is clean so clean it with alcohol prep
and let it dry now with glass
thermometers you have to pay attention
to where the liquid is on the reading
scale if it is above 98.6 degrees
Fahrenheit you will have to take your
wrist and flick the thermometer down for
that fluid to go below ninety eight
point six degrees once the fluid in the
thermometer is below that point you'll
want to insert the thermometer in a
probe cover just to protect the
thermometer from being contaminated any
more and then take the thermometer and
insert it in the patient's mouth have
the patient lift up their tongue and put
it underneath the tongue okay keep it
closed and wait for three minutes and
then remove the thermometer once the
time's up you'll take the thermometer
out of the patient's mouth and read the
thermometer then what you'll want to do
is remove the probe cover clean your
thermometer with alcohol prep or
whatever your facility wants you to
clean it with Dolph your gloves perform
hand hygiene and document the
temperature
especially the route now let me show you
how to check an oil temperature using a
digital thermometer of course what you
want to do first is perform hand hygiene
and dawn and gloves and make sure you're
working with a clean thermometer so
always clean it with alcohol prep then
you're gonna take the thermometer and
insert it in its probe cover then turn
the thermometer on by hitting the button
on the thermometer and insert it in the
patient's mouth have the patient lift up
the tongue and then put it over and then
keep the mouth closed and then once the
thermometer is done it will beep once
the thermometer beeps take the
thermometer out of the patient's mouth
and read it then when you're done taking
the temperature be sure to remove the
probe cover clean the thermometer / your
facilities protocol with alcohol prep
and doff your gloves perform hand
hygiene and document the temperature
another way you can take a temperature
is through the ear via the tympanic
membrane so first what you want to do of
course is perform hand hygiene get your
thermometer and with these type of
thermometers you want to use a probe
filter so place that just over the
thermometer turn your thermometer on and
you're going to insert this in the ear
for the adult what you'll want to do is
you want to take the pin out of the ear
pull it up and back if your patient was
less than 12 months of age you would
want to take the pin up and pull it down
and back so we're going to pull it up
and back we're going to insert the
thermometer in the ear then we're going
to hit the button to take the
temperature just takes a second then we
will read our thermometer and it will
display the temperature right here then
after reading the temperature what you
want to do is take the probe filter off
and perform hand hygiene and clean your
thermometer / your facilities protocol
and document the temperature a third way
to take a temperature is through the
armpit back Silla so to do that what you
want to do is get a digital thermometer
perform hand hygiene make sure your
thermometer is clean and insert it into
a probe cover then turn the thermometer
on and lift up the person's arm place
the tip of the thermometer directly into
the armpit not on the clothing have them
close the armpit and hold the
thermometer there until it beeps once
the thermometer
phoebs take it out and read it after
reading the thermometer reading take the
probe cover off clean the thermometer
perform hand hygiene and document
another way to take a temperature is
through the temporal artery so to do
that of course we want to perform hand
hygiene get our thermometer and with
this specific thermometer it has a cap
cover so take it off it does not have
the little filters that go over it some
models do the manufacturer just
recommends cleaning the thermometer so
make sure your thermometer is clean with
alcohol prep or whatever your facility
requires you to do what we're going to
do is we're going to hold in this button
keep it held we're going to go to the
middle of the forehead and swipe a
thermometer across the forehead to the
hairline and then release the button and
read our temperature now let's say that
the patient was sweating had a lot of
sweat on their forehead how we'd want to
do that is again hold the button in go
through the middle of the forehead sweep
across to the hairline and then go
behind the ear and read our thermometer
then clean your thermometer recap it
with the protective cover perform hand
hygiene and document another way to
check a temperature is rectally so to do
that you want to perform hand hygiene
and dawn gloves when checking the
temperature this way you want to get a
thermometer and you want to make sure
it's clean then insert the thermometer
into a probe cover and then lubricate
the tip of the thermometer then turn the
thermometer on and have your patient
positioned on their back with their
knees bent then insert the flowmeter
into the rectum about one inch then
remove the thermometer once it beeps and
read the temperature measurement after
reading the temperature take the probe
cover off clean the thermometer off your
gloves perform hand hygiene and document
another way to check your temperature is
through the skin using a temperature
strip and to do that you want to perform
hand hygiene peel off your strip and put
it on the forehead and after placing the
strip within 15 seconds a dot will start
to appear and whatever turns green will
be the temperature reading then once you
have read the temperature just take the
strip off and dispose of it then perform
hand hygiene
and document now you may be asking
yourself which route is the most
accurate according to the experts the
rectum is the most accurate route to
take a temperature the least accurate
route would be the skin or the armpit so
always use that as last resort and
whenever you take a temperature in the
rectum it's always going to read about a
degree higher than the mouth and if you
take a temperature in the armpit it's
gonna read about a degree less than the
mouth thank you so much for watching and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more videos